this video is brought to you by full
sail university
what's up guys michael here to talk
about the original content behemoth
netflix once chiefly a purveyor of
movies and red envelopes netflix has
quickly established itself as the film
studio of the future releasing a
staggering 129 original films in 2021
alone and the pipeline isn't slowing
down anytime soon but as you get flooded
with trailers for their latest movies
maybe you've wondered do all these films
kind of look the same don't worry you
don't need new glasses netflix does tend
to hue to a unique look and feel and
what's more the netflix aesthetic has
real implications for the film medium at
large we'll explain in this wisecrack
edition how netflix is changing film but
before we get into it i want to tell you
about today's sponsor full sail
university what's up guys i am in winter
park florida today at full sail
university we are here for their hall of
fame celebration week and uh let's go
check it out full sail university
specializes in preparing students for
careers in the entertainment industry
emerging technologies and gaming to name
a few and because they have so many
successful graduates they spend a full
week every year celebrating these alumni
during hall of fame week we were lucky
enough to spend some time at full sail
during the hall of fame celebration the
campus was absolutely buzzing with
activity as students were checking out
panel discussions with new hall of fame
inductees enjoying an afternoon at the
silent disco and prepping for the annual
cosplay competition we also checked out
some of the amazing resources available
to full sail students they also unveiled
their brand new virtual production
studio during hall of fame week and we
were lucky enough to attend the ribbon
cutting ceremony as well as get an
exclusive tour to see studio v1 in
action this is the same type of
technology used to make shows like the
mandalorian and full sail students will
have the opportunity to use this studio
in their own creative projects i even
got to jump on their hall of fame live
stream which they run throughout the
week to highlight all the alumni and
special events okay guys if you want to
learn more about everything happening
here at full sail head to fullsail.edu
or click the link in the description and
now back to the show over the past few
years netflix has solidified its move
from giant movie platform to gianter
movie maker adding plenty of popular and
profitable titles in its library and
they've got range from foreign language
prestige pictures like ramin barani's
the white tiger to action westerns like
the harder they fall to the vaguely
disturbing gerald's game at first glance
these films don't seem to have all that
much in common but dig a little deeper
and you'll find plenty of aesthetic
similarities take the cinematography it
tends to feel very slick manufactured
and smooth even barrani who previously
made a name for himself directing gritty
realistic dramas essentially subsumed
his style into this cleaner look netflix
films also tend to share a similar color
scheme with deeply saturated hues that
render the actors practically
phosphorescent and make the slums of
india or a wild west saloon look almost
as lush as the mansions and he's all
that at the same time the images are
relatively low contrast making them easy
even pleasant on the eyes even the use
of focus tends to be pretty uniform
often evoking a glamorous softness that
would have been standard fare for say a
1940s melodrama so what is this look
really amounting to let's examine the
sum of the parts slick functional
cinematography low contrast lighting
saturated matte colors and simple
no-nonsense compositions this all makes
for an easy comfortable
non-confrontational aesthetic which is
to say it's basically ideal for passive
consumption while folding your freshly
laundered collection of wisecrack
t-shirts the passivity these films
mostly engender seem to be part of the
point as matt singer writes for screen
crush it's not that these netflix movies
can't be enjoyed while you are
distracted by your phone or your tablet
it's that they are undeniably better
that way of course there are exceptions
for example prestige films made by big
name directors like martin scorsese the
irishman or alfonzo corones roma but
more than anything these exceptions only
make the overall house style of the
platform stand out even more compare the
richness of the colors in the irishman's
film photography or the expansive scope
of roma's widescreen framing to your
average netflix original and you'll see
just how different these movies are from
the norm and the netflix norm when it
comes to style of filmmaking is actually
ideal for how the site itself is built
namely the fact that netflix hinges on a
very specific type of cinematic
experience one that never ends how many
times have you just finished watching a
great movie on netflix soaking it all in
as the credits roll only to be snapped
out of it the moment the trailer for
tall girl pops up obviously netflix
wants people to watch as many of their
films as possible so auto playing a new
flick asap helps with that this all
leads into the effects of netflix's
algorithmization of its films you
already know about netflix's famous
embedded algorithm that tracks the
content you watch among other things so
that it can recommend other movies and
shows you're also likely to enjoy and
what's an easy and almost subconscious
way of convincing you that you'll enjoy
the next recommendation if at first
glance this new film looks like the last
thing you watched and that's what makes
this trend towards homogeneous
aesthetics such a valuable tool now
there is an argument to be made that
algorithms can actually be more
democratic than curation instead of
relying on critics or that film school
hipster you went on a date with ai uses
your own personal taste to determine
what movies are worth your time but
while this sounds great in theory the
actual result doesn't always work out
that way in practice algorithms often
skew rather conservatively that is to
say they tend to rely on a known
quantity of data they have about you
rather than risk surprising you with an
outlier that might not suit your taste
in other words if the platform detects
that you have previously enjoyed films
like mystic river 7 and the shawshank
redemption then the algorithm will take
a lot of factors into account in order
to cater to your tastes which probably
means they won't suggest you watch say
paddington 2 which is a shame because
that movie is a masterpiece and when we
say they'll take a lot of factors into
account we are not kidding as todd
yellen netflix's vp of product told
wired magazine the algorithm is able to
split users into 2 000 different taste
groups based on the explicit and
implicit data that each user had shown
that includes both data actively given
by you like a thumbs up rating or
passive data collected like your
infinite scrolling through oscar
contenders or the time you binge squid
game in one week now this system sounds
sophisticated enough but it can still
easily fall prey to algorithmic bias
it's pretty convenient and generally
pleasant to receive more movie
recommendations that remind you of
what's in the box but it can also lead
to a feedback loop scholar dalyan jin
argues that the algorithm's goal of
serving up a new movie that you're
certain to like functionally limits your
opportunities to explore films in a
variety of genres or themes what's more
the algorithm typically keeps viewers
culturally confined by for example
mostly recommending american films to
american viewers what's the point of
paying for access to a gargantuan
library if you're functionally never
going to expand your horizons but when
this starts feeling even more sus is the
fact that the algorithmization of
netflix extends far beyond your personal
cue it can actually affect the new works
of art that are being produced way back
in 2018 former vp of original content
cindy holland told vulture that netflix
was green lighting projects based on 70
human analysis and 30 data from the
algorithm data including specifics like
how long you watched a given film
whether you stopped watching because it
was too scary and whether you stuck
around to start yet another scary movie
only to step away like a little coward
or maybe maybe that's just me anyway we
suspect that data has been given an even
more privileged position at netflix in
recent years but call that speculation
now it's one thing when film tropes
evolved naturally through popular
culture but when the computer starts
playing storyteller we get a little
shiver down our spine it's not that it's
dystopian i mean i mean it might be but
it's also often bad take the new ryan
reynolds film the atom project which
vulture perfectly described as feeling
like a fake movie designed to check as
many genre boxes as possible to maximize
its chance of success but critical
misfires like superhero time travel and
ryan reynolds encountering his childhood
self can't stop netflix's algorithm
estimated to be worth a cool one billion
dollars it's clearly seen as valuable
for its ability to predict what people
will want to watch based on what they've
previously enjoyed and to state the
obvious this isn't entirely unique in
the entertainment industry studios have
always used past successes and failures
when deciding what to make next or when
predicting box office hits but obviously
netflix has the great gift of big data
to make those decisions more approximate
more scientific and ultimately less
risky which is why some of the rest of
hollywood has been taking note and
starting to consult ai during the film
development phase what's more netflix
arguably has more sway and influence
over the industry than just about any
other company that's perhaps why we see
its aesthetic making its way into the
industry at large so what does it mean
when netflix makes its content decisions
in tandem with an algorithm that's
predicated on your previous cinematic
taste well when you're more worried
about holding attention and keeping
butts on couches than you are about
making good art you arguably lose much
of what makes cinema so important in the
first place the risk factor see most
films that are truly provocative and
compelling probably wouldn't make it
through the old netflix algorithm the
reason cult classics are usually
delightful is their sheer shock value
would netflix greenlight a film starring
an unknown actor about a curly-haired
weirdo in idaho who plays tetherball all
day heck would a retelling of the
odyssey set in depression-era america
sounds sexy to an algorithm and how
would something as weird as tree of life
ever possibly make it past netflix's
head of content now it's no surprise
that in our tic-tac-happy culture
commercial filmmaking in general has
become more preoccupied with keeping you
from looking away via high voltage
special effects laser fast editing cuts
and so on but we think algorithms take
it one step farther when they assume
that we're only down to watch what we've
already watched but regurgitated of
course there's a decent argument to be
made that much of cinematic history has
been somewhat self-cannibalizing and you
don't have to look at four generations
of a star is born for evidence the
assembly line logic that fueled
hollywood's golden era often meant
rearranging your contract actors in
various tropish roles like a strong
silent type or the manipulative vamp or
the plucky young innocents these
characters would then almost inevitably
go through storylines of lost love love
regained and hey maybe there's a peppy
musical number in there too still
hollywood nonetheless exhibited what
scholar janet steiger called a drive
towards product differentiation
stressing novelty and innovation in
order to lure audiences to the cinema
again and again they needed people to be
actively excited to watch netflix
doesn't have the same burden it's often
the background soundtrack to your
domestic life and arguably what keeps
you from turning it off is familiarity
or sameness that is entertainment that
reminds you of previously enjoyable
entertainment or as we like to call it
algertainment
is that not catchy is it not
well okay i'll never say it again we can
understand this via the philosophical
movement of post-modernism and its
application to aesthetics which has been
percolating in academia since the 70s
post-modernism is predicated on the
notion that society has become so
fragmented that there's been a breakdown
in subjectivity i.e there is no longer
any consistent and universal truth that
grounds how we view art or our own
subjectivity if we used to all have a
loose agreement on what counted as art
or cinema we're now in a free-for-all
where a tick-tock is as valid as a
scorsese film this comes with
challenges as literary critic frederick
jameson explains if indeed the subject
has lost its capacity to organize its
past and future into coherent experience
it becomes difficult enough to see how
the cultural productions of such a
subject could result in anything but
heaps of fragments in other words when
it no longer feels like there are
universal truths and concepts that help
you make consistent sense of experience
over time it's harder to turn your
unique experiences into art and it's
even harder for a bunch of folks with
disparate experiences and perspectives
to all agree on what art even is in the
first place let alone agree on what art
is actually good so where do we get the
raw material to create those heaps of
fragments we start pillaging dead
artists of course as jameson puts it in
the postmodern era the producers of
culture have nowhere to turn but to the
past the imitation of dead styles speech
through all the masks and voices stored
up in the imaginary museum of a now
global culture he calls the practice of
invoking or straight up reviving old
styles of art pastiche and considers it
a fundamental tool of making post-modern
art of course pestice isn't necessarily
a bad thing without pastiche you
wouldn't have pulp fiction or the novels
of thomas pynchon or the sparkly 60s
camp of hairspray the postmodern turn
reveled in the idea that no piece of art
is purely creative that were all
cross-inspired by other artists past
present and future and postmodern
artists used various techniques of
ripping each other off to make truly
groundbreaking work as wide ranging as
blue velvet and monty python and the
holy grail but not all works of
postmodern art can be brilliant jameson
acknowledged that post-modernism
necessarily implied a sort of cultural
stasis and in that stasis the supreme
value of the new end of innovation fades
away against the steady stream of
momentum and variation that at some
outer limit seems stable and motionless
where everything now submits to the
perpetual change of fashion and media
image nothing can change any longer so
you get a lot of sameness and a lack of
new coherent artistic styles
simultaneously as jameson explains what
has happened is that aesthetic
production today has become integrated
into commodity production generally and
now faces the frantic economic urgency
of producing fresh waves of ever more
novel seeming goods at ever greater
rates of turnover in this way whereas
art objects used to have value relative
to their beauty or aesthetic style they
are now simply commodities to be
produced and sold it's not shocking that
jameson wants to find post-modernism as
the cultural logic of late capitalism so
just as originality is slumped to a
crawl demand for production has
skyrocketed and who does that remind us
of our good red enveloped friend of
course now to be clear netflix hasn't
dedicated itself to the postmodern
project the way that the cool kids at
art school have they're just trying to
get more eyes on their movies for longer
periods of time to be clear we're not
saying all movies used to be
masterpieces some cinema used to try to
be art while some was content being
popcorn blockbusters and netflix has
tried both strategies to amass its giant
portfolio of original work all in
attempts to achieve its supreme goal of
maximizing watch time it's not even up
to us to say if that came at the expense
of quality because netflix's cool ted
sorandos has implied as much himself in
response to critics panning netflix's
film bright surrando's defended the film
saying that critics speak to specific
audiences who care about quality or how
objectively good or bad a movie is not
the masses implying of course that the
masses don't care about objective
quality and that netflix is okay not
actually delivering it this reminds us
of philosopher theodore adorno's
critique of mid 20th century popular
music as scholar c.w smith explains
adorno believed that people were
listening to popular music without
actually listening because they were
experiencing what he called a breakdown
in mediating subjectivity or the
inter-subjectivity of the experience
between the subject and the piece of
music that is to say people were so
inundated with homogeneous pop music
that they started consuming it
mindlessly rather than engaging with any
single song thoughtfully for adorno this
was about more than just spacing out
though he contended that this sort of
undiscerning consumption of art
indicated a broader social tendency
towards obedience even an acceptance of
authoritarianism which can prevent us
from becoming free-thinking reflective
individuals that is to say when we stop
thinking critically about the art we
consume we become less autonomous and
instead more pliable suggestible and
easier to coerce the interminable
sameness adorno observed he believed led
to both a regression and quality of
hearing and the more or less stunting of
experience such that the listener was
docile and afraid of anything new and
that sense of safety and familiarity
sounds pretty familiar when we think
about netflix as we've discussed netflix
films are made for the sort of watching
non-watching adorno diagnosed in
mid-century music listeners and there's
reason to believe viewers might indeed
be afraid of anything new stephen
follows founder of vod click stream
which analyzes netflix data argued in a
podcast that when people watch netflix
they're sitting down and watching stuff
that is comfortable that is easy to
understand that won't challenge them the
appeal of the algorithm is its
infinitely watchable lack of
confrontation and look we're not
monsters we love us some easy watching
as much as we love frank sinatra lord
knows i've watched the episode of the
office where dwight quotes mussolini
about 76 times
blood alone moves the wheels of history
but does constant easy watching come at
the expense of our ability to really
watch and when arguably the world's most
powerful media corporation commits
itself to making movies we're all but
guaranteed to half watch does it change
the way we engage with the medium
overall and when we consider the
algorithmization of most aspects of our
modern lives the problem starts to feel
way scarier but hey at least we get to
watch is it cake but what do you guys
think when it comes to netflix films are
we actually getting the cinema we want
or merely the cinema the algorithm
thinks we want what's more
are we inadvertently creating our own
cinematic hell when we hate watch some
of netflix's more mediocre content let
us know in the comments big thanks to
our patrons for all your support please
go check out our revamped patreon page
we have lots of good stuff on there hit
that subscribe button like you're
jumping up to give the tall girl a high
five and don't forget to ring that bell
and as always thanks for watching later
[Music]
you